did you hear Jon Hamm on our show
um last week I saw
um a little video you guys posted he was
talking about coming over to my house to
watch football it's funny because that
was before anybody knew who John was he
wasn't a famous actor at that time he
was one of the guys who came to my house
on Sundays but he told the story when
before he was famous he actually met Tom
Cruise at your house which is
mind-blowing you know Tom Cruise
arguably the biggest star in the world
in terms of movies right Tom Cruise is a
big Giants fan but um I was talking to
him about the Giants or whatever and I I
said hey you know we have football on
Sunday if you ever want to come over not
thinking he would ever come over because
this is a bunch of like I mean if you
could see this group you I mean John
Hannah's not Jon Hamm is not indicative
uh I mean these are mostly my cousin
Sal's friends from upstate New York
these are not glamorous people by any
stretch of the imagination it's not a
Showbiz crowd not a Showbiz card this is
the kind of a crowd that like one of the
guys will like go into my mini bar and
drink all the little pineapple juices
one after the other and just leave the
cans all over the place like that kind
of a fruit so Tom Cruise uh comes over
and
um
and he brings his mom uh over also this
has got to be a lot of pressure for you
because it isn't a Showbiz crowd and
then you're thinking to yourself oh [ __ ]
Tom Cruise is here now he's not going to
have a good time because he's going to
be uncomfortable around these guys so he
comes over and first of all my dad gets
hold of him in the backyard and start
telling him about real estate in the
area and this is not particularly great
neighborhood I live and he's like and
this house sold for uh in 1.4 and it was
on the mark you know he's going through
all the stuff that I know Tom Cruise
doesn't care about at all but Tom is
pretending that he does care I finally
go I go dad Tom might want to watch the
games he's here to watch football so Tom
comes in Corolla lives down the block at
this time Adam comes over and he gets
lit I mean he gets he just gets a
hammered because he knows he can walk
home you know right right Adam gets
drunk and decide and somebody encourages
him to do his his uh touchdown
celebration dances End Zone celebration
dance which is him uh what he does he
tends to to score a touchdown he then
squats down uh pretends to [ __ ] the
football out of his ass
hey the foot drops it like he's on the
toilet and [ __ ] and then he thumbs
through the newspaper he mimes thumbing
through the newspaper it's hard just
imagine this and imagine Tom Cruise's
mother watching
Adam did the whole dance he did the
shooting did the whole dance he [ __ ] out
the football in front of Tom Cruise's
mother
it was crazy but Tom stayed from the 10
from the yeah the pregame show until the
late game I mean he watched all the
games and uh and we had fun it was nice
so he had a good time never never came
back of course that was the last I heard
from that